aj green drafted in the first round by
the cincinnati bengals in 2011 last year
of his contract he said he wants to stay
in cincinnati the way that larry
fitzgerald has stayed in arizona but
there's trade chatter regarding green
and green has acknowledged that you have
to be ready for anything and he is ready
for anything two weeks and five days
until the trade window closes for good
at least for this year
he says i tell everybody i haven't heard
anything i don't fantasize about
anything like that i'm just trying to
get healthy and go from there i'm
prepared for anything and trade's not
going to change who i am i'm still going
to play i'm still going to be aj and the
patriots fans have been smitten with the
idea of aj green for a while chris and
you know crazier things have happened
and and this is the ultimate bill
belichick move get a guy in the last
year of his contract i don't know what
you have to give up to get him but you
get him in the last year of his contract
so if you can't work out a deal with him
beyond this year you get the
compensatory draft pick if he leaves
after the season ends yeah yeah exactly
i mean it's kind of a no-lose situation
and a team like new england you know and
a guy like aj green
i'd almost expect him anybody that
traded for him is going to sign him he's
still you know got a lot of good years
left he's certainly still in the cream
of the crop as nfl wide receivers are
concerned yeah the patriots are the one
or one team that certainly jumps out to
me uh when i think about that if there
is a possible trade destination for aj
green the other one is okay to flip it
to the other conference if i'm the green
bay packers i'm calling the cincinnati
bengals too i mean most people i talk to
can't even name the receivers on the
green bay packers so that just tells you
they need somebody there to help out
just a little bit uh and if they could
get one weapon like that in the pass
game and then along with the devonta
adams who's been banged up and we'll see
how he is this week uh then that could
be really dangerous and they're in the
window right now defense is good rogers
is still really good got a run game i
would think about it if i'm green bay
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports